we need to come together write a film
and cast
people in scenes that are gigantic next
to us and we make it it's not even about
the film it's about us it's about us
like being open about it yeah and just
putting on like no we are small yeah
it's like jason momoa yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the first name right jason
yeah yeah yeah okay no no this is tough
josh
sorry yeah frank
you love josh
gaslighting me i do love yeah josh yeah
now that i've learned what actually like
it means to gaslight because i didn't
really understand it up until like i
don't know [ __ ] three weeks ago i
think it's the funniest thing ever
just
is it jazz light
oh that's right pronouncing it all
[ __ ] up it's like jelena oh it's like
that that's just light yeah if either of
you ever caught yourself potentially
gaslighting in an argument
sure yeah and then i'm like you know
what let me stop myself right there yeah
yeah
speak the truth
i just read them more like sometimes
like i'll get late and i'll get into
some stupid argument and then i'll say i
did something with a lot of confidence
and then i'll have a second later where
i go did i do that and then i'm like
yeah yeah then i'm like gaslighting her
and i'm gaslighting me and i have to
double down yeah i think gaslighting is
just an accident yeah really yeah
exactly yeah i gaslated a gaslighted a a
famous nfl
quarterback did you see that whole saga
he basically gaslet jared goff
from um who's he played for now the
lions yeah i met him in person
i'm like yeah
gosh the lions of course who are who who
are they um football team okay yeah from
where yeah yeah what's their vibe
they're cool dudes are they winners
are they i don't know nah they're you
know they play for the love yeah jared's
a winner in my eyes okay okay he's my
close personal friend oh greg
he's not but i
made him in person one time and he was
like yo you're cody right and i was like
yeah he's like i think we met at the
charity softball game and i was like
yeah yeah yeah no that's not never been
to one of those yeah yeah you're not
allowed i've never donated to a single
charity
okay
i'm joking i'm joking
i'm joking
and i just was like yeah well because
you're trying to help him out you're
trying to make it so that you're not
like no and why do you think that yeah
trying to be like you know what you're
right in thinking that and i yes i'm
with you and we're friends i was doing
him a service you were i really think
he's yeah yeah yeah yeah i really think
he benefited from that i like i would
i'm with you and we're friends i'm with
you we're friends i support you yeah
yeah yeah
i met you at the thing yes and we are
close personal friends yeah yeah yeah
he's just business partners yeah yeah
yeah
we should work together
just grabbing his hand is like i knew
this would happen
i knew this way where did the lions play
where detroit
oh have you been there yeah we've been
there on tour twice i think yeah yeah i
hear it's cheap to buy a house in
detroit yeah you guys got any houses
yeah we bought like three did you yeah
yeah picked up a couple yeah yeah that
was it was cool we just the highlight
was we went to this
uh like wings place
and uh oh yeah
those were genuinely to this day i think
some of the best wings i've had in my
life so detroit has a positive memory
for me but yeah hooters yeah yeah yeah
that's awesome yeah that's where
straight guys need
yeah there's this wings place yeah yeah
yeah it's a little hole in the wall it's
only one a little local joint called um
yeah something like that
hooters actually has incredible wings i
go to hooters sometimes as a gay guy and
i feel like it's like this is great like
i don't
you know i'm i'm here for all the right
reasons
[Laughter]
they do have really good wings though
they really do
tell the waitresses like you can relax
yeah i'm like
it's fine honey yeah it's like it's just
us here yeah they're just like they're
just like oh thank god
there is a thing when you compliment a
really beautiful woman as a gay guy
where you're like where you're a little
bit like oh wait i need to make sure i'm
like
like
like letting her know that i'm gay yeah
she doesn't think that i'm hitting how
do
you
[Laughter]
you know
because i'm so masked in real life i
have to i have to be like i'm sorry this
is i'm not underneath i am
you have excellent boobs but i think
they're gross yeah yeah but for me it's
not something i would like they're
getting all like aggravated they're like
[ __ ] you're straight yeah they're
like kiss me yeah
you end up getting married to her and
you're like how did this happen how was
the meal all the time so what's the last
like
year been like for you it's been great i
mean tick tock is is so great do you do
you guys have a i feel like i have an
unambivalently positive experience of
tick tock do you guys relate to that or
is it more like i don't know um like as
a user or as a creator both i i get and
probably my experience being so positive
as a creator on there
informs me
enjoying it as a user but i i also just
like i'm just always like damn this
algorithm is so good because i didn't i
didn't which is such a funny thing it's
so like future tech to be like now this
algorithm i like but it really is like i
i didn't think anything was funny on it
for the first like week or something and
then it like learns who you are and then
it's like oh actually some of the
funniest [ __ ] i've ever seen is on tick
tock yeah i don't know it's it's
definitely i think you're right and i
think we're all like weirdly attuned to
the algorithm yeah and how it affects
our life now yeah like you used to make
jokes all the time like the sketch ideas
that you had of like
appeasing the algorithm and treating it
like a person yeah yeah i always thought
those were like a little bit abstract
but nowadays it's like people don't
[ __ ] realize how much the algorithm
affects your life and how much we're
like
sensitive to it yeah and as a creator
especially like when you're making
something you know whether the
algorithm's algorithm's going to pick it
up and yeah yeah
yeah
definitely
i was ahead of my time yeah yeah you
were dude no
i think
maybe that sketch felt too abstract
because i like a [ __ ] 10 year old i
had i just had to make it sexual me like
flirting with the youtube algorithm
being like damn
you going to treat me right this time
maybe
if you upload the right thing whatever
yeah yeah what would be the right thing
please just [ __ ] tell me
and i'll make it can you tell me
yeah
make a slime video
do a crap
[Laughter]
i don't feel like i have any knowledge
of what the algorithm likes from me as a
creator and that's like that's like
random like here's another video and
sometimes i even notice that i'm a
little bit trying to make videos people
would like and then i'm like oh wait i
need to shitpost more because i feel
like i i guess my only experience of it
is the algorithm like knows if you care
and then it's like no no no yeah that's
not a space for that you know yeah so
now i try it's like it's like wait a
minute i'm like getting to like well
people really like this character so i
it's like no no i need to like react to
something and like you know throw up
right now yeah no it's some kind of not
give a [ __ ] energy yeah funny um
algorithm's just yeah it is kind of like
dating it is yeah yeah yeah too needy
yeah yeah stop being weird yeah it's
like more of this yeah
yeah when you get on there and you're
like i made you something i took like a
really long time like [ __ ] i know
and i feel sometimes i feel really
highly i'll see really highly produced
tick tock videos and i'll just like feel
a little bit bad for the person because
i'm like
you must like spend so much time making
these and then this algorithm is just
like
yeah yeah you know and it's like because
i don't i i guess over time it has some
kind of wave effect where over time it
can start to
see what you do and honor it yeah anyway
yeah we're talking about just so i mean
i do like the fact that it's clear you
don't really give a [ __ ] about
the algorithm or what works on tick tock
or whatever you make [ __ ] that
people like like it's so clear every
single one of your videos is made for
the people that like to watch you do
what you do yeah what happens with me is
just if i start
caring and trying to do things the right
way
it's like my kryptonite it's like i do
so much better i just i guess i just do
so much better when i can get kind of as
lazy as possible
and then
and then basically not make anything for
a while and then like whatever erupts
from that
the most organically is but but i often
think like yeah but that's why i don't
have millions of followers that's why i
have like three but then i try to trust
and i'm like yeah but you will
eventually if you just keep trusting
this you know no i think uh millions of
followers comes from
yeah right
i think like and i don't think you want
i don't think you want that like
yeah you want millions of followers just
like right off the bat from doing some
stupid viral [ __ ] right because the
people that like you i just have to jump
in and say the people these are my
managers by the way yeah
that's what this whole thing is i just
have to say real quick no we're trying
to sign you
ryan listen love your stuff
yeah my kids love your videos so much
that is so much you are gonna be i'm on
board yeah yeah